you're not alone not anymore
do you know what mutants are i'm so
excited to be talking about new mutants
and
i know you are finally
you're very excited a few days ago
we saw a new trailer for new mutants and
we all know
this there's a special panel coming up
at comic con at home this week
can you tease us a little about what we
might be able to see
there yeah i mean you're gonna see uh
kind of a new kind of virtual round
table with uh with myself and our
wonderful cast uh
and then you're gonna see the beginning
of the movie really the opening of the
movie followed by
some amazing stuff maybe you haven't
seen before yet kind of
i think people be excited to see it i'm
excited to show it to him
no i i can tell you right now that the
fans are going to be thrilled because
there's a lot of fans out there that are
really really excited to see this movie
now new mutants really blends genres
like horror and superhero right and
we've seen this trend emerge a lot in
the last few years like
logan and joker what makes blending
genres
like this a compelling way to tell these
kinds of stories
well it was funny i was just looking for
a way to tell the demon bear story which
is sort of a famous story arc in new
mutants uh it's like a three issue story
arc that's very famous and uh
we responded that it was already sort of
a horror story and once we kind of found
a place to locate it and set it we were
sort of able to dramatize it uh
i didn't think that much about mixing
genres it just sort of happened
naturally as we
as we wrote it and as we made it because
of uh what we brought to
what the cast brought to it and uh you
know just kind of became this strange
interesting thing i think it's uh i
think it's not like any other comic book
movie i can say that i think
definitively
awesome yeah we're all comic book fans
like a lot of
a lot of the fans of the movie and chris
claremont wrote some amazing stuff so
show of hands everybody who who read the
comic before
they were in the movie
[Laughter]
okay okay and then who read
who read the comic after they heard they
got their role
oh okay
but i i i think uh with that horror
thing from the comics that josh was
saying
um it's kind of impossible to tell the
new mutant stories
without the horror our traumas are so
severe and so intense like
it's not like we're trying to push any
element uh it
came totally naturally yeah that's
that's especially with the human beings
because it becomes a thriller the demon
bear i think brings that thriller
quality to it right
chris and bill's run on it really gave
us told us what it needed to be
so it's like we just sort of gave our
we've tried to be a vessels to
kind of dramatize all that and try to
capture some of that darkness and
humor and friendship and all that and
there are several speaking of horror
there are several like horror movie
references that we saw on the trailer
now
i'm assuming there's some of the film
like when danny's on the bed and we see
the faces pushing through the wall
that's classic nightmare on elm street
in this movie i'd say
i'd say one of the big you know one of
the big movies that we really made and i
loved a lot for this was
one of them was nightmare on elm street
three dream warriors where it's a bunch
of kids stuck
in a mental institution and freddy's
there with them so i mean that was like
uh
a way to figure out how to tell this
story and contain it
and you love this genre so it's really
cool to have done this with you right
josh because you really love
this type of genre like it's it's in
your heart i think it really
you bring to life in a beautiful way but
it was
fun you know it's just like stuff that's
fun that really plays into teen movies
that i love from the 80s and the 90s and
uh joss whedon stuff like buffy the
vampire slayer which uh which you'll see
a little bit of in the in the movie as
well
now uh charlie a couple questions for
you
you shot this film in between i think it
was season one and season two of
stranger things
think back uh between season two and
season
season three okay so what are the what
are the some
what are some of the similarities
between sam
guthrie and jonathan byers
um i mean you know i i mean i'd like to
say that they're
kind of both very you know very
different characters um i mean they have
this similar sense of
responsibility i guess in their
family life uh and kind of a sacrifice
of you know this is backstory for sam in
our movie but it's uh
you know a similar kind of doing what
needs to be done i mean
sam you know he leaves school to work
with his father in the coal mine to
bring in money and
you know we've seen with jonathan in
stranger things where you know he
worked at a movie theater and he you
know he has this kind of
man of the family concept so i guess it
would start there but
almost kind of end there at the same
time i think um
sam is yeah i mean one you know the
mutant aspect but two just as a person
and where he's
from is um yeah is i'd say very
different
and you know i mean charlie was really
playing a character that suffered from
post-traumatic stress disorder and panic
attacks and things like that which just
make the physicality
and uh just all those things so
different from any role he's played
before
in my opinion yeah yeah and and also
you're playing a character whose pancake
attacks
trigger i think his mutant genes so
there's also that side effect no
completely and that was something we
really wanted to you know
that was something that you know really
wanted to manifest like you said in into
this power
also psychologically what that means and
you know the physical act of a panic
attack comes
you know from from the stress of
situations and and
how to get past that how to stop that
and how to
be like it's okay to you know have these
feelings and control them so
it was a real good ground point to kind
of yeah
take that kind of superhero esque thing
but make it kind of
you know real and personal this isn't a
hospital
it's a cage
[Music]
blue speaking of
i trauma remember the demon bear saga
okay danny goes through
some stuff so and this is a little it
feels like a little bit of
danny's origin story um danny moonstar
is
not just one of the first few first few
first nations characters and comics but
she's also one of the most powerful
mutants
basically because what she dreams about
can become real
what going into this like what is a
dream that you've had
that you wish could become reality oh a
dream that i had i wish the
movie coming out
[Laughter]
um yeah i mean dreams i mean
what are those um i mean i don't know i
a billion
jillion dollars for everybody in the
world
[Music]
for peace but i mean
um that's probably actually changed a
lot what i what i used to want and what
i want now after
quarantine and yeah everything that's
been happening
um recently in this in this world um
yeah that was a beautiful answer
it was blue blue are you ready for the
fandom
like henry you i hope you clued her in
because superhero fandoms and
genre fandoms are yeah
the best fans should have
meant to come out the first time and it
was overwhelming and
very exciting just to see feel the love
it's like
you know they're screaming your name but
like they don't know who you are they
just want to see the character and it's
like whoa
yeah something that they believe in
deeply you know yeah i
i think i'm i'm excited for it too for
the
the attention it will hopefully bring to
first nations and indigenous people yeah
a lot of people don't don't know there
are there are still reservations and
there are many native people
this is you know this is our land and
you know i i just
i'm excited for fans to
learn about a new um
something new that they don't know about
maybe in a very modern way because danny
is written really well
i think to really embody both you know
the pros and cons of growing up on
a reservation um the good and the bad
so i i'm excited for that part of i
guess
fans the rest of it i um i don't i don't
really
i don't know we do have wonderful fans
though they've they've posted so much
incredible artwork on instagram that we
always
pop back up there like people seem to
love these characters so much and these
actors and these roles i'm just excited
for everybody to see the performances
and
get to experience the movie yeah no
they're absolutely amazing in fact
alice in the comics dr cecilia reyes
is actually a mutant herself and she has
the ability
to project force fields all around her
body
force fields that look a lot like the
one that we've seen in a couple of the
trailers
make sure the perfect makes her the
perfect caretaker for these dangerous
mutants
it's the perfect power for you to care
take up like you know
young people
if i could put my kid in a force field
when they were having a temper tantrum
that'd be amazing
for every person in america partying
everywhere when there's a pandemic
that's true that's that's really good
yeah we actually need dr reyes right now
she's a
and she's doctor doctor so everybody
stay where you are stay within the force
field and i will take care of you
at least we'll take care of you exactly
um alice do you feel
that your character and i know there's
only so much you can tell us
but in our heart does she really care
about the people that are that are
in this movie does she really care about
these kids
yes i think so i mean like it was very
interesting and i love the way that
josh and nate they brought you know this
character this world
because she's the one that is from from
a different um uh
comic but it was very interesting to to
not
play like you know you know in like in a
in a classic way of like just being
you know the caretaker and being the
annoying one that is taking care of the
kids but trying to understand why they
should do it and why does she care and
why
why is she guiding them so i think that
kind of feel i tried to bring it away
because she does have an like a desire
with this
with young kids so i think it's kind of
like that i do think she cares
in her own specific way you know she's
like it's
an antagonist and a protagonist she does
care and like
is trying to help them you know so it's
interesting to see that like it was
interesting to create and hear a lot
what josh was envisioned like
for for this character and kind of go
through the backstory and one of the
things that
charlie was saying about him creating
you know uh his character it's like it's
so beautiful to see
this character coming to life because i
think for mutants like
for x-men and for x-men world and also
new mutants world especially new mutants
it's different than some type of genre
of the
you know like of the marvel world just
because sometimes they're already heroes
and here they're just you know young
people trying to figure out
dealing with it and i think it brings
for the actors
and for the journey of the film a
different depth in a way because
really as a fan and as an audience you
connect with that journey
in a sense and you try to understand
what they're going through and that's
why you root for them even more because
you feel
you know that compassion it's more than
just action but it has
that kind of you know have that kind of
depth yeah behind it and that
that is all in the writing now henry i
gotta i have to ask you
not just what was it like when you found
out you were playing a superhero
but sunspot a brazilian superhero
it was like uh i couldn't sleep for so
many days i mean
uh three months before i even heard
about the first audition and i didn't
know why i was meeting josh and
nobody told me not even my agents after
the meeting
they just said like oh there's this
really cool director you should mean and
he has a secret project and i think we
really hit it off from the beginning and
as the year progressed it took about 10
months to get the role
i realized like oh it's a hero but it's
like a brazilian one
and i'm kind of close to playing it and
i was like
this is insane it's like after the first
meeting
in my phone i put him down in his
sunspot zaga
he was already the carry i was already
like yep
um
yeah yours is yours is still charlie
cannonball
oh god uh sunspot man
it was so exciting it's uh i'm eternally
grateful to this man and for
casting me twice in roles that i'm
very excited and and just
you know as an artist and as a person to
to play
all of you are dangerous
that's why you're here i have to ask the
last few questions i need to know
uh think of all of the mutant powers
that you have everybody has
in the in the movie if you can trade a
power
with another mutant which power would
you pick
and why like in in just in you know
you know just a new yeah justin newman's
you're stuck with destiny newton sorry
i really want a dragon so magic man i
was gonna say magic just because she can
pop in and pop out the dragon's a huge
selling point
i like his prison um i don't know
you know yeah man that's cool
um yeah i mean i can't control mine so
it's not that fun
and you know that's what i'm teaching
you
yeah like in the comics eventually
cannonball really gets it together and
he's extremely powerful so
in 20 years when you make the second
movie i'm
[Laughter]
and blue i'm actually curious danny and
rayne's characters obviously we we can
tell in the trailer
they had a fall for each other is it is
it because of the like the desperate
situation they're in
or is there a true connection is there
something else there
i definitely think it's a it's a true
connection yeah i mean i
love one of the i don't know if i can
say this i mean one of the first things
you ever
the first people that danny the first
person danny meets
is is rain and i think right away it's
like whoa
you know some real love at first sight
kind of
energy
but i mean the situation that they go
through definitely
uh quickens i think their relationship
and
and being stuck together obviously um
it quickens their relationship i think
maybe it would have taken a while for
them to
you know um get brave enough to you know
go for it but um in this place you could
die
it's their love that really i think
it's rain's love for danny i think that
really gets danny through
everything she needs to get through i
think without rain i don't i don't think
danny would have been able
to julian you know in life you need
other people
so it's really sweet yeah and really the
movie is about friendship
yeah now i have to ask this question
uh specifically josh and and
henry i gotta ask a stand question in
here
sure so like we're kind of in the middle
of a pandemic
and the stand kind of starts off with a
pandemic just want you
this is like apocalypse now like did you
do something you were not supposed to do
i don't know i don't know i'm hoping not
i will say that the the pandemic in the
book is much
more lethal than the pandemic in real
life uh they couldn't be more
on the opposite sides of extremes but uh
but yeah no that was great i directed
the first and the last one and uh cast
mr zaga is uh nick
andrews who uh uh who's a very special
character and very different from this
one
yeah now how do you how does it feel uh
also for you um henry playing nick
andrews
like pretend josh isn't listening for a
second and tell us what it was like on
the set was like doing it
i mean this is actually crazy so josh
actually didn't direct
uh correct me in the stand because
really
i directed the first episode in the last
episode
or the last i just cast him and put him
in it
[Music]
it was like bye like later
cassian you said lose weight and then
you left
i was like get real skinny oh oh so he's
the reason why you couldn't eat anything
when i met you
listen i'm not david finch if i found
that he wasn't eating i would be feeding
him
but josh was always like dude you gotta
eat something and drink water uh
he wasn't i was the worst friend because
it was the opposite i was like
change your body be like no let nobody
recognize you or
you think you're you're a cannibal like
like not kind of sunspot like do
something different i was a crazy friend
yeah i mean it was a really special
opportunity to play
such a a sensitive character in a
in a world of his own you know he's not
he lives in a hostile
a hearing world and being born deaf
he has to navigate the world in a very
different way
he's homeless he's a drifter and he just
relies on
kindness and i think that's very
different from roberto
and the new mutants i mean in some ways
he has similarities like he was
abandoned by
by everyone and gets to lead his life
um in his own way but um
their upbringing is completely different
and it's
again a testament to josh for seeing in
me what i couldn't even see that i could
play these
these like opposites um
and yeah i'm eternally grateful so my
racer
thank you so my very last question
everybody
can uh give me a really short answer on
this what is the one
thing that you want everybody to take
away from
new mutants and i'll start with josh
i mean i guess i'd say how important
friendship is and that people doing
stuff together is better than one person
alone
i was going to say that friendship and
union i think like once you connect as a
community
like as a team as a you know it's
union is is a powerful thing for all
civilization
right now that's why
badly it's like don't measure wounds
with people as you go by life you know
everyone has their baggage
and we just need to come together and
become better people
i i think the the measuring traumas is
not a not a good place to start and we
all have um you know
mm-hmm how about you charlie yeah i mean
i was kind of going with what
henry was that you know you everyone has
these you know scars and
lots of people like that uh and you know
to be able to forgive you i think
there's a big thing about forgiving
yourself as well is that that's a big
theme in the in the movie and blue you
have the last answer
oh um yeah i was gonna say yeah about
forgiving yourself that
i think you can get through anything um
that like no matter what everything is
going to be okay
i think um no matter how whatever you're
going through no matter how hard it is
but you have to face yourself first to
do that
we can get out of this together
[Music]
you